HOW'S IT GOING SQUADFAAAAM
Today I wanted to ~flex~ on you, fam
cause i have the new Honor 7X, i know, you're jealous
I'm a huge Android fanboy
I had the previous version of this and I'm super happy with this thing
So, OBVIOUSLY, I'm gonna show it off
It's got a full view feature, which makes the screen even bigger when you're playing games
It feels amazing in your hand, seriously.... I could touch this thing all day
The screen is amazing, the color is amazing!
I've been playing in a couple games on it, and I never get lag, it's super smooth
It's the perfect phone for gaming and I couldn't be happier with it. Honestly. It's a perfect phone for gaming
I couldn't be happier with it, and the best bit: the battery life. I've been playing for 30 minutes. The battery hasn't even moved.
I'm super super impressed with it, and I'm not just showing off this time
I'm actually gonna give away five of these to you guys
So just check out the link in the description and you can win one of these as well.
I'll start the video, I just need to finish up, don't worry about it.
~Check out: link in the description~
Hellooooooo
Everybody
Got a microphone, green screen, what?! Pewdiepie really stepped up the quality
And I noticed that and I'm gonna leave a like on this video because of that.
MY GOD, It's hot in here!
Here. We. Go.
...interaction with people
Cant wait to interact with people... This is definitely the most normal way you can do that
..The fuck is this?!
I spent all that time loading for this?!.. Dude. Oh my God.. alright..
What the hell, where are you going?
Hey man, hey hey hey, hey you, hey hey hey, hello
Hey, hey, hey you, excuse me excuse me excuse me excuse me,
Excuse meee! HELLOOo. HELLOOoo?
HELLOOOo ...
HI! HI! AHHHH! DAHHH!
You wanna dragon ball them?.. Hey look. It's me!
HELL YEA MAN....
*pterodactyl screeches*
Why is being social so difficult, it's hard enough in real life!
how [do] I interact with people online?
how?
TELL ME! I want to be social
I want to communicate
I want to meet friends, but here I am alone in space..  ah
Holy shit, I can be Guts... ho! ho! Oh!!
OOOOooh! OOooh! OOOOOOooooh!
This would be a lot more fun if I had friends... wait I can be a Yoshi car
Great.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Pew pew, pew pew, pew pew!
Hey, HAI, HEY!
Hey, hey, hey hey hey hey hey hey, hey, hey what's up?
Can you guys hear me?
Can you see me? (here take this bow)
(It's a submarine) No, It's a Yoshi submarine.
(Guys can a submarine beat a robot?) YES IT CAN!
I don't think they can hear me still.. Hello, can you hear me hello? Hello? Hello, CAN YOU HEAR ME?!
CAN YOU HEAR ME??
Hey, hey.. hey, hey... hey... HEY, hey hey hey, hello... hello.. hello, hello, hello, hey
Can you hear me? Can you hear me? Hey. Can you hear meh? Helloooo.
Hey, hey buddy, hey, buddy, can you hear me? Can you hear me?
*whispers* Can you hear me?
Hello. Hey..
Can you hear me. Can. You. Hearah Meh.
UUUAHHHHH!
(You!) Yes!
(Join us!)
No!
(*unintelligable* become a poopy butthole?)
Where do I become poopy butthole?!
(hey come on) yes?
There he is!
(come on, come on, don't be shy)
Should i do it?! Should i do it?
I can't go closer!
No, no no!
No! (Salad ass, you better do it) No. Nope!
(Choose the poopy butthole!)
Okay, alright I'm gonna do it!
Alright I'm gonna do it!
OOOOAHHHHH! One of us, one of us! Oh ah oh!
REEEEK!
Where's the Szechuan sauce? (Oh, okay, it's you)
REEEKK!
Where's the Szechuan SAAAAUUUCE!
I'm pickle RIIIICKKK!
(HEY! Fucking.. salad ass..) Yeah what up fam?
(How you doing?) ...Not too bad man
Jesus fucking christ.. what is that? Let me.. come on.. let me.. let me touch it
(I will swallow you whole if you don't give me your gold right now.)
Listen... listen fatty. Give me your fattest dab, and I will.. think about it.
(What did you.. what did you call me?)
I called you a fat son of a bitch huh, what you gonna do about it?
(Okay, everyone turn around. I don't you to see this)
No. no.. Hey, hey, hey, I have a wife.. please. stop, leave me alone!
Where'd all the poopy butthole go?
(All the poopy buttholes went to the different world, man)
Which world? Take me there. Please my life depends on...
(Alright Pewdiepie bro) What, I'm poopy butthole. What are you talking about?
(Wait are you.. are you the real poopy butthole?)
I'm the real poopy butthole, that's right. I keep trying to tell you, everyone.
(Prima, do the little dance.)
The poopy butthole dance?
(Yes, right now) (Oh shit! He is the real one!)
That's right, that's right, I've been trying to tell you guys!
(Everyone else is a faker!)
I know, everyone else has been faking me. Cause none of them, can do this. That's right. That's right.
Look at this dance
(The gods are up there, we worship these gods.)
Oh i see!
(He must be very high.. You see.. yes. Fate has praised them, yes! Get down on your knees! Worship!  worship...*laughing*)
What is the benefit of this cult?
(*laughing* Um, good healthcare!)
(You can get your IQ over 3,000)
Healthcare! Hell yea man!
(free healthcare and your IQ increases by tenfold)
Tenfold? I feel smarter already, you're right..
(Yo penguin, everyone get the penguin)
Yeah get the fu--- penguin ahhhh ablalaalla AHHHHH!
KIYAAHH! AHHHH! AHHHH!
Come over here you son of a bitch!
*suspenseful music*
*tension heightens*
Get the fucking penguin!
Where did he go? (fuck where'd he go)
Goddammit (where'd the penguin go)
(He's right there!)
*suspenseful music intensifies*
(Where's Saladass?)
Hey, penguin, penguin if you join, we'll give you massage. (Oh WTF)
Alright, let me just let me just (Yeah,  look. He'll give you a little massage)
(Ah yeah, you like that penguin?)
This is just the beginning
(What the fuck am i witnessing?!)
One of us, one of us! *chanting*
(Alright Saladass is my second in command)
No no no no, I'm the leader.
(No, we've been through this)
We voted and i won! Let's have a vote! Let's vote!
This is a democracy!
(I call for a revote)
This is election night in America.
Listen: there will be free healthcare, for everyone, at all time...
(You cant steal my idea!)
No, shut up, shut up. I will offer the same healthcare, but get this:
It's better.
(Yeah)
That's right. Yeah. I know.
(How is it better, explain to me.)
Free tacos.
Every Friday, I will do... the hardest dab I have ever done.
To prove to me that this man is not worthy... (You're so lucky you have a vibe system, otherwise..)
Here it comes.... are you ready?
(HEADPHONE USERS RIP)
P A A A A A!!! AHHH!
A A H H
*USA National Anthem*
(squadfam out)